déjà 4000 licenciés en France 8000 si
l'on compte nos compagnons à quatre
pattes les sports de tractage canin sont
en plein boom ce week-end 200 équipages
étaient présents à la couronne un
rendez-vous de course à pied VTT ou
encore trottinette mais toujours
accompagné de chiens entre performances
et bien-être animal à reportage de
Faustine lune
près de 200 chiens au même endroit à
Pernelle l'association les acrobates
avaient organisé pour eux un week-end
entier pour se défouler au programme
plusieurs compétitions de sport de
tractage canin alors avant le départ
leur compagnons humains sont au petit
soin un petit peu chaud pour les toutous
alors je le mouille un maximum pour
qu'il conserve cette fraîcheur au moins
le plus longtemps possible sur sur le
parcours c'est un parcours de près de 6
km se met d'obstacles sur lequel se
mesurait les participants venus de toute
la France tant en canicross que dans
d'autres disciplines moins courantes le
canive VTT et le Cany trottinette j'ai
commencé mon VTT puis après je suis
passé en trottinette parce qu'il se
rapproche plus de l'attelage
que prévu pour la course c'est super
allégé
je peux la soulever en cas ou si j'ai
des obstacles qui sont compliqués
c'est beaucoup plus d'adrénaline parce
que les réactions du chien peuvent être
complètement inattendues
mais pour ces amoureux de la discipline
le bien-être de leur compagnon à quatre
pattes passent avant tout on peut tout
faire avec son chien il faut juste
mesurer l'effort et jamais oublier le
plaisir du chien c'est pas inné
forcément de courir grande vitesse sur
des distances assez longues pour un
animal donc il faut il faut adapter le
travail qu'on lui demande à ce qui est
capable de faire l'animal verdict à
l'arrivée ce n'est finalement pas le
chien qui en a le plus bavé très
physique j'étais pas du tout à la
hauteur par rapport au chien je m'en
excuse devant lui
parce que elle a bien bossé et moi dans
les côtes j'étais comme j'ai plus besoin
j'étais obligé de marcher
c'est très technique mais alors le chien
extraordinaire et comme quoi le travail
paye je pensais que ça allait être
compliqué mais avec le chien tout est
plus facile et ça finit par une grosse
côte avec beaucoup de physique et elle a
bien bossé je suis très fier d'être je
pense qu'il va il va bien dormir une
bonne récup ouais un repos bien mérité
pour ses duos de sportifs la Fédération
française des Sports et Loisirs canins
comptent déjà plus de 4000 licenciés